انضم الينا من جنيف كريستيان لماير
المتحدث باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه ضيفنا
انتم كفريق زرتم هذه المستشفيات الان
نتحدث عن الجنوب واحتماليه تكرار سيناريو
الشمال ما حدث في المستشفيات ونوهت الى
الخطوره العاليه تحديدا في مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح ما السبيل لحمايه هذه
المستشفيات لما
تبقى من وضع صحي ونظام صحي في القطاع
شكرا للاستضافه والسؤال الذي تثيره هو نفس
السؤال الذي اثاره مدير المستشفى لزملائنا
عندما كانوا يزورون المستشفى يوم
الاحد وهو احمو هذه المستشفى فهي المكان
الوحيد الباقي للناس في هذه المنطقه كماو
وكم كانان لتقديم الرعايه الصحيه
والمساعده نعم الوضع عصيب جدا نحن في
منظمه الصحه العالميه يمكن لنا ان نقدم
المعدات الطبيه والادويه والاغاثه ويمكن
لنا ان نقدم اللقاحات وحتى
الاسره مع القوافل ولكن بهذا فنحن بحاجه
الى وقف اطلاق النار او على الاقل ممر
انساني يوصلنا الى المستشفى
هذا امر مهم ولا يحدث نحن استطعنا الوصول
هناك يوم الاحد وتقديم بعض المساعده وبعض
الادويه ولكن لا يمكن لنا ان
نضع نظاما او درعا فوق المستشفى لحمايته
اذا فنحن هنا نتحدث عن المناطق المحيطه
بالمستشفى لانه اذا كانت هذه المناطق
المناطق قد تم اطلاق امر
باخلاقها فان المرضى في المستشفى والفرق
الطبيه ومن هم موجودون يجب ان يرحلوا
ويتركوا هذه المنطقه لحمايه عائلاتهم
وانفسهم اذا فهذا وضع عصيب للعائلات
وللمرضى
وللفرد ما يكون هناك اخلاء فهناك اخلاء
الى مناطقه ايضا مزدحمه اذا فالسيناريو هو
مزعج
جدا
جديد يعني انتم زرتم الاحد من الاحد الى
اليوم يعني حدثت هنالك تطورات كثيره وانت
تعلم من خلال فرقكم ان التطورات لحظه
بلحظه لكن في هذه المنطقه في في دير البلح
هذا المستشفى هي المنطقه التي يطلب الجيش
من الناس التوجه اليها منطقه دير البلح
وهو المستشفى الوحيد كما قلت الذي يخدم
الناس هناك سواء النازحين او او
المصابين وقلت لا يمكن توفير قبه حمايه
للمستشفى المستشفى فعليا تعرض بعدكم
لاطلاق
نار وتحدثت عن طرق امنه للوصول الى
المستشفى هل تحذرون بشكل واضح من ان
المستشفى الان لا يمكن الوصول اليه يتعرض
بشكل واضح
لخطر
الاخلاء نعم ذا هو ما نخشى منه لاننا نخشى
ان ما يجري وما جرى في الشمال هو الان
يتكرر في المنطقه الوسطى وفي الجنوب ايضا
فالمستشفيات هي لا تعمل بكل طاقاتها فقط
ست مستشفيات في الجنوب تقوم بما عليها
وبوظيفة
وهناك عدد قليل من الطواقم الطبيه كما ان
الوصول الى المستشفيات ايضا صعب جدا بسبب
القصف لذلك هناك مجازفه وخطر بان ينهار
النظام الصحي لان الناس لا يمكن لهم حتى
ان يصلوا الى القليل من المستشفيات التي
هي قادره على تقديم القليل من الرعايه
الصحيه ما هي الردود المقابله ما الذي
يصلكم من ردود ومن مواقف سواء من الجانب
الاسرائيلي اذا ما تواصلت معه للمرور الى
هذه المستشفيات وتزويدها بالخدمات او
الطلب بحمايتها او المواقف الدوليه الاخرى
وانتم منظمه امميه في هذا
السياق نحن نسمع ما نسمعه كل يوم ونحاول
ان نجهز القوافل ونحن ننتظر مع القوافل
لكي تنطلق لكي تزود مستشفيات في الشمال
بما هو لازم ويجب ان نرى ان كان هناك اذن
لنا بالتحرك وان يكون هناك ممر امن لنا
لكي نتوجه الى هذه الاماكن نحن تواصلنا مع
السلطات الاسرائيليه ومع دول اخرى في
العالم ومن تمتلك القوه ايضا ونتواصل معهم
كل يوم ونسمع الكثير من الكلام ولكن
التحرك الفعلي على
الارض
يخالف الكلمات التي
نسمعها نحن ليس لدينا تدفق مستمر للمساعده
وليس لدينا سبيل لاخلاء منهم بحاجه الى
اخلاء وليس لدينا رعايه تقدم في الوقت
المناسب وهذا يجعل الناس لا امل لهم ولا
مساعده تقدم اليهم ابدا بالنسبه للشمال
اعلن عن التوقف وعدم القدره اكثر من مره
على الوصول الى المستشفيات التي تحاول
العوده للعمل في في الشمال منذ اكثر من
يوم ما تفسيرك لعدم القدره
ولعدم وصول هذه المساعدات والامدادات
الطبيه الطارئه الى المستشفيات الشمال في
ظل حديث اسرائيل عن تقليل عدد القوات
وتقليل مستوى التصعيد في غزه
والشمال صوفيدي
نحن لا نرى هذه الكلمات تترجم الى تحرك
فعلي ملموس على الارض نحن نعلم انه تسع
مستشفيات في الشمال اليوم تعمل اي انه
عندما يكون هناك اطباء وممرضون يروا فرصه
للعوده الى المستشفى ومحاوله تقديم بعض
الرعايه للمرضى يقومون بذلك اذا فكلهم حقا
هم الابطال في هذا المسرح لانهم يقدمون
الرعايه في كل وقت ممكن للناس المحتاج
حتى انهم يخاطرون ويجاز فون بحياتهم
وارواحهم فهم ما زالوا يقومون بكل ما
عليهم ولكن لا يمكن لهم ان يقوموا بهذا
بطريقه مستدامه فهم بحاجه الى المواد
والمعدات وهم بحاجه اللامم المتحده
والصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر ولكن ان
كان هناك قصف مستمر فلن يكون هناك سماح
لهؤلاء بان يقوموا
بعملهم هذا يمكن ان يقام به
وان لم يكن هناك وقف لاطلاق النار فاننا
بحاجه على الاقل الى هدنه انسانيه وحيز
انساني من خلاله نقدم الرعايه للناس نبقى
مع مع الشمال وهي المنطقه المحاصره بدون
امدادات
غذائيه او صحيه وننتقل الى جانب اخر لا
يقل خطوره انتم حضرتم بالنسبه ل الامراض
المميته وبعض المشكلات الصحيه التي لا
يمكن
تداركها مستقبلا ما هي يعني الخطوات التي
يجب ان تتخذ صحيا و غذائيا لانقاذ
المحاصرين في شمال
القطاع انت محق تماما في اي مكان نذهب
اليه وفي كل مكان نذهب اليه نسمع الامهات
والاطفال والاباء
يبكون بسبب حاجتهم للطعام والمياه الناس
يواجهون صعوبه خاصه في عدم وجود المخابز
ولكن معظم الناس الان يعانون من النقص في
الغذاء وهم يعانون من الجفاف وبالتالي من
هم ضعفاء الان او هم
مصابون يمكن لهم ان تكون اجسامهم عرضه بكل
بساطه لاي مرض سواء كانت الامراض متعلقه
بالامراض التنفسيه او الرئويه الان سجلنا
الفي حاله وهناك اطفال
ويعانون من اليرقان ومن الاسهال ومن
الجفاف
والاسهال اصلا يمكن له ان يفتك
بشخص صحته ضعيفه
اصلا ولذلك راينا هذا في اطفال الذين هم
ادنى من خمسه اعوام من العمر هم بحاجه الى
الطعام والى المياه والى الادويه اذا فهم
بحاجه الى كل هذا وعلى السلطات
الاسرائيليه ان تجعل هذا ممكنا شكرا جزيلا
لك من جنيفا كريستيان لين ماير المتحدث
باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه